Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. This will be my Superman Man ofSteel 2 video they revealed what the plot of Man
of Steel 2 was going to be when Henry Cavill was
still Superman they had a bunch of different plans
for the future of Superman up to about October
before James Gunn was hired then he elected to
reboot all of DC movies so Henry Cavill had filmed
some other cameo scenes that I'll explain and
they'd written Man of Steel too so we'll explain
what the plot of that was going to be and what
their original plan for Henry Cavill Superman was
heading forward into more Justice League sequels
and eventually a movie version of crisis on
infinite Earths if you're brand new to the channel
obviously there's a bunch of chaos and DC movies
right now James Gunn said that he would reveal the
full DC Phase One really soon so of course I'll
do videos for all that stuff be sure to subscribe
to get all those videos because there'll be a
lot of big stuff happening in the next couple
of weeks but writer Steven de Knight who wrote on
the original Smallville series with Tom Welling
Superman Back in the Day in the Daredevil Netflix
series a bunch of other stuff revealed the plot
of Man of Steel 2. he said that he'd written it
for the studio before James Gunn had been hired
the actual plot confirms a lot of our fan theories
about where they would take Man of Steel too like
we're talking about man of tomorrow like where
are they gonna go with the Superman character
after the Justice League Snyder cut which big
comic book villains from Superman's Comics would
they introduce that he hasn't fought yet what
had happened is that Henry Cavill originally
had worked out a handshake deal to come back once
in the Black Adam movie with the understanding on
his part that the studio would make Man of Steel
too and he just become a much bigger character and
in October 2022 right after the Black Adam movie
came out Warner Brothers the studio Executives
in charge of all that specifically told him to
announce his Grand return to Superman and T's
Man of Steel 2 with more future Superman projects
more future appearances from his character we then
found out that he'd already filmed another Cameo
scene for The Flash movie which is coming out in
2023 this year I wanted to wait until the weekend
was over before posting this because I wanted to
give you all the chance to watch Black Adam but
now that plenty of you have I wanted to make it
official that I am back as Superman and the image
you see on this post and what you saw in Black
Adam they're just a very small taste of things to
come so uh there's a lot to be thankful for and
I'll get to that in time but I want to thank you
guys most of all thank you for your support and
thank you for your patience I promise it will
be rewarded during that clip the upcoming stuff
that he was teasing was a combination of those
cameos that he filmed for the DC movies coming
out in 2023 like The Flash movie Cameo which I'll
explain but also the Man of Steel 2 movie like the
next solo Superman movie you probably remember
a couple months ago the CEO of Warner Brothers
making all those statements about them refocusing
their efforts on DC movies making Superman a much
bigger priority than he's been in the past so
everybody was like oh this is great news for
Superman fans we're going to be eating really
good and at the time that all those Superman
announcements were being made earlier this year
Henry Cavill had already filmed his Cameo for
The Flash movie it was going to help set up their
movie version of crisis on infinite Earth's future
Justice League movies reportedly he was supposed
to show up to the flash appear to him when he was
inside the speed force and he would have teased
some coming big crisis like their movie version
of crisis on infinite earth like they did on the
TV show but just like way way bigger originally
the studio had their own 10-year plan for DC
movies that would have culminated in crisis on
infinite Earth so they had all these other movies
that they were planning they were going to use
The Flash movie to help set that up like tease all
this upcoming stuff by November though like just a
month after he posted that video on the orders of
the studio James Gunn was hired elected to reboot
all DC movies like they just wiped the Slate clean
and start fresh and reportedly they removed Henry
cavill's Cameo scene from The Flash movie because
if you think about it if that was meant to set up
like the next 10 years of their original plan why
tease a bunch of things that they weren't planning
on paying off because James Gunn had completely
different plans there was also supposed to be a
Gal Gadot Wonder Woman cameo in The Flash movie
too they might have removed that I did a video on
it a couple days ago because there was like a clip
with the director talking about Gal Gadot Wonder
Woman about a version of Multiverse sod being
one of the villains I actually got contacted
by Warner Brothers they're like could you please
remove that part of the video the filmmakers don't
want that part online I was actually surprised
to hear that Wonder Woman did have a cameo during
The Flash movie is they really did remove those
Cameo scenes from The Flash movie hopefully at
some point they'll release them on deleted scenes
or just release them separately from the movie
because it sounded like they were really cool but
while the Studio's original plans were being made
those cameos were being filmed they were still
planning on making Man of Steel 2 like the next
solo Superman movie meeting with writers preparing
scripts and writer Steven denight revealed his
version of Man of Steel 2 was like the last one
that they had settled on before James Gunn was
hired and decided to get rid of Henry Cavill
and basically passed on his script like in his
statement he basically says that the movie that
he wrote didn't jive with James Gunn's plan for
the future of Superman because we found out James
Gunn was writing a new Superman movie himself with
a much younger version of the character and that
was the whole reason why he recast Henry Cavill
what would have happened originally though is that
in his Man of Steel too it would have picked up
after the events of the Blue Beetle movie if you
look at the DC movies timeline here this is only
current as of 2023 a couple things got delayed
like Aquaman 2 is coming out a little bit later
at the end of 2023 now and between now and Man of
Steel 2 Superman would have had a few more cameos
so that he wasn't totally absent on screen for a
couple more years before the movie actually came
out I believe they would have released the
movie around 2025 so you would have started
hearing them casting and directors all that new
use in the next year or so we don't know a ton of
their plans for the movies that would have come
out in 2024 and 2025 aside from Man of Steel too
but we did hear about Wonder Woman 3 which they
also canceled recently and we found out about a
legit Batman Beyond movie with Michael Keaton and
Terry McGinnis that the studio was planning on
making before the reboot that would have also
probably come out around 2025. the studio had
a lot of plans for Michael Keaton's Batman in
the next couple of years really good example of
that is the Batgirl movie which he was in that
they canceled as well the actual events of Man
of Steel 2 would have had Henry Cavill Superman
facing a version of dceu Brainiac and it sounds
like the plot would have been somewhat similar a
little bit different but similar to the plot of
the more recent Brainiac storyline in the last 10
years or so back during the big New 52 reboot Jeff
John's Gary Frank did a big Superman Arc kind of
reintroducing the character reintroducing a lot of
his core characters and villains like Brainiac so
Brainiac comes he faces him defeats him and in the
process winds up releasing a lot of the bottled
cities that bring I could capture including the
bottle city of Candor where Supergirl comes from
releasing thousands of kryptonians on the world
which will remind you of Lex Luthor's quote
during Batman v Superman kind of tying things
back around to the earlier Snyder verse movies
the red capes are coming way more Kryptonian
stuff happening on planet Earth just in general
for better and worse Man of Steel 2 wouldn't have
directly adapted the comic book storyline there
would have been some Easter eggs for that so it
would have been the exact same story it still
would have been relatively original but for
example they were introducing the new Sasha Calais
Supergirl during The Flash movie she's still in
the movie but the future of her characters kind
of in question now with James Gunn's reboot her
Superman symbol looks exactly like the same
design as Henry cavill's Superman symbol so
it sounds like even though she comes from the
Multiverse the version of Krypton that they both
came from the planet is very similar I think is a
way to tie her character to Henry Cavill Superman
so they could be together in a movie I don't know
she was supposed to be in Man of Steel too but it
does sound like they had plans to sort of weave
the those characters together they didn't say
whether or not Lex Luthor was a big part of
Man of Steel 2 or if they were bringing back
Jesse Eisenberg Lex Luthor it's hard to continue
doing Superman in movies without doing a version
of Lex Luthor just because he's so critical to the
character Ben Affleck has still planned on leaving
the role of Batman that wasn't going to change
he'd still filmed a cameo scene for Aquaman 2.
I don't know if they deleted that as well too now
because of the big reboot but because the way they
reshuffled the movie is Aquaman 2 was supposed to
be his last appearance as the character as far as
we know and they'd originally planned on using The
Flash movie with the flashpoint twist to set up
Michael Keaton's Batman is the new Multiverse
crossover Batman who would show up in all the
future Justice League movies whenever they needed
it in between the movies it would just go back to
his earth like he can't do a Justice League movie
without Batman in it so they need a Batman and it
wasn't going to be Robert Pattinson's Batman so
that's where they get to Michael Keaton Batman
what's happening now though as James Gunn already
revealed he wants to reboot the majority of all DC
movies recast most of the roles with new actors
including Henry Cavill Superman he's been right
fighting a new Superman movie which will be one
of the first new movies in his DC Phase One it
sounds like they still want to make Superman
a priority but just not Henry Cavill Superman
with a younger version of the character earlier
in his career but it's not meant to be another
origin story like he was clear that it wasn't
retelling the origin story and it'll be more
like Superman year 2 which is almost exactly like
the same Vibe as what Matt Reeves did with Robert
Pattinson Batman movie that was a movie set during
Batman year two still figuring out what the Batman
character is going to be what his whole ethos is
how he's going to save Gotham City in the best
possible way Batman hasn't become a symbol yet so
the whole idea is the same thing is happening in
this new Superman movie Superman is still kind
of workshopping who the Superman character is
going to be to the rest of the world and because
they're starting out with a new younger Superman
it sounds like in all the DC Phase One movies
they're sort of Shifting the timeline so that
when things pick up all the Justice League
characters are much younger versions like a
younger Superman means a younger Batman younger
Green Lantern younger flash so on so forth the
only real exceptions to that are people like
Wonder Woman and Martian Manhunter even though
it sounds like they might recast with younger
actors they're still super old chronologically
one of the weird things though is that James Gunn
did say that Robert Pattinson's Batman will not be
like the Justice League crossover Batman and they
are planning on doing a new Justice League movie
in the next four to five years which implies they
also plan on recasting another new younger Batman
actor because around the time they'd be releasing
this new Justice League movie like Justice League
rebirth whatever they're gonna call it Robert
Pattinson would still be in the middle of making
the Batman 3 with Matt Reeves at the pace that
they're going I suppose they could always delay
the new Justice League movie like another year
or two to give Matt Reeves time to do the Batman
3 and then maybe make Robert Pattinson's Batman
Crossover with the Justice League movies or they
just flat out recast the new younger Batman so you
can let me know in the comments do you want them
to just wait on Justice League for like six or
seven years and then have Robert Pattinson show up
or do you just want another younger Batman to show
up and see Justice League in the next like four to
five years he'll be making his announcement on
what those upcoming DC movies are going to be
in the next couple couple weeks of course I'll
do videos for it make sure you enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss that there's also a
new Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania trailer video
with Kang dropping next week of course I'll do a
video for that The Last of Us episodes are also
starting really soon too I will be doing episode
videos for that everyone click here for that new
Flash trailer and click here for that new Henry
Cavill Warhammer trailer video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!